what is the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested
the person the guy who she's talking to
the guy who she's talking to do you feel
like women make it clear if they're
interested or not interested nah cause
some women like the idea of someone
being interested in them but like no
interest in the person so like they
might like string it along so like
sometimes it's really unclear like they
like the attention yeah yeah definitely
what is the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested
about how easy she is in bed
no [ __ ]
do you feel like um women flirt because
they like the attention 100
100 but they have no actual interest in
the guy yeah like obviously like
situational but like yeah there's times
where like
girls will be flirting and they've got
no interest
in anything except like they like how it
makes them feel do you think that makes
it confusing for men
yeah obviously like it's a bit like you
know it's definitely confusing like some
guys would be like i don't even know
what i'm doing here like yeah we're on
it we're not on it so yeah do you feel
like women actually know what they want
hmm
you know what i'd say like some
do not they want but i think
what they want and what they like is
kind of like there's real blurred lines
so i think they might not want like a
bad guy or something like a bad boy but
like
everything they say they don't want it
but everything else that they talk about
is like kind of catered towards a bad
voice so like it's kind of like they
like the bad boy but they don't want to
like the bad yeah yeah exactly exactly
what is it the difference between a
woman playing hard to get and not being
interested
oh wow
that's such a good question
what's the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not interested
i guess a woman playing hard to get
will
give you
a tiny sign sometimes okay just a little
carrot okay or a piece of cake okay to
say hey come and get me okay where's
someone
not someone a woman that's totally not
interested
i say this is literally nothing there
for you to
entertain do you feel like women flirt
for attention yes
do you feel like women go on dates for
attention
yes
why everyone
um
i think
some and this is maybe oh not both
species
some women maybe maybe more
transactional as as the generations have
gone on
and yeah they're more transactional i if
they
see a free dinner or
a fun night out they'll just do it for
the hell of it do you think that makes
it confusing for men absolutely
because
guys can be led on right yeah i mean it
could be both ways yeah just be honest
guys can lead girls on yeah but um
yeah in terms of when it's dating going
out especially if the guy is making the
effort to take her out and whatnot can
be very confusing for a guy what is the
difference between a woman playing hard
to get and not being interested
the difference between a woman playing
harder and okay
well some of us some of us keep it real
okay some of us i don't have to say
anything my face says it all
yeah and some some women are mean so
they'll play hard to get just to make
the man suffer but i'm not one of those
if i'm not interested you know about it
my face tells you do you think women
flirt for attention
yes um oh and if you're a confident
woman and you're on a power trip and
then you're how should i say celebrating
your deliciousness then yeah you flirt
because the men flock to you like bees
and you flare because you feel good
because you know you look good yeah do
you think that makes it confusing for
men though when women flirt with them
when they're not interested actually yes
i do feel sorry for some of them but
some of them they need it keep them on
their toes
yeah some of them deserve it why is it
when a man makes money he wants more
women but when a woman makes money she
says she doesn't need a man
that's a great question
that's like a clinical psychologist
question right i guess
[Music]
i guess the answer to that would be i'll
ask the question again while i digest
why is it that when a man makes money he
wants more women but when a woman makes
money she says she doesn't need a man
[Music]
wow
it's quite i mean i guess it's quite
subjective because some some guys that
do make money are quite happy with one
like like who
i've made money as i've gone on i'm
happy name one billionaire oh
that's not married to a smoke show model
true
just remarried right why why did he get
divorced yeah yeah
yeah doctor bill gates dr dre bill gates
but is that them wanting more women is
that is that them wanting more women i
mean jeff bezos why did he get divorced
why did bill gates that that was his
wife that called it home right that was
his wife yeah melinda well why did she
call it off
was he having illicit relationships yeah
really
yeah he went to epstein's island
yeah
i mean
i mean that in itself is a bit he had
like so many sexual harassment lawsuits
against him at work he did not know that
yeah
wow
okay
you're backing up your argument well
here you're you're researched i'm not
researched uh like we're not talking
there's are there gonna be specific
instances yeah but in general
men tend to get more women women don't
need mad mad
yeah i guess i guess
this may sound
i'm not trying to make it not sound
sexist
predominantly
most of the
you know like the ftse 100s i don't know
what's called in the states but the big
100 companies in the uk i think it's
like 92 percent are male ceos so it's
like seven eight percent women right
so i guess when a woman gets in a
position of power
she's more focused
and but aren't the men more focused too
well research will say that they're
they're probably not they're they get a
bit um complacent
and complacent and what well evidently
their private life oh you're saying in
their private life
the power gets them right whereas i
guess for a woman maybe when she gets
into a
an area of higher power in her work
she can maybe distinguish between work
and pleasure better
do you think maybe it's because they
don't have access to the type of men
they would want
that's a great point and probably yes
women are attracted to power but men not
so much absolutely
very well put and society would only
tell you that it's it's more accessible
for men to get women
that are as you put it maybe more
promiscuous but are not as powerful yeah
whereas for a woman to get
a promiscuous guide that's not so
powerful a bit harder right because
don't really do that
nightclubs
point it's hard for a woman to get a
promiscuous guy no i would say
compared to a man you know going to a
list a nightclub let's say
it's i think so it's easy it's easier
for a man to get sex than women oh see
that's different see that's different
okay okay that's that's very different i
think if you're going to uh
[Music]
like a nightclub okay
a man a man in power i think it's easier
for them just to just to go home with
someone you don't think it's easier for
any woman to go home with anyone
i'm a girl i've told you it's pretty
yeah it's pretty easy but i wanted to
like
i think do you know what it is i think
maybe going back to the transactional
thing i think uh
the
younger girls may be blinded by the oh
the the the hybrid they're attracted to
it yeah yeah yeah oh attracted to it
maybe a better word uh but maybe i've
not seen it's maybe not seen it so much
for whatever you don't really see oh
it's more rare exactly it's more red
yeah it's more rare you always say
high-powered women in nightclubs so much
then then like like beaut like pretty is
common yes but yeah i'd say
like a one percent guy i'm so intrigued
by this uh then why is it that when a
man makes more money he wants multiple
women but when a woman makes more money
she doesn't need a man
because
men are like babies
so they do that kind of stuff women
don't need to do that because we're
strong we're strong yes see i think it's
because women when they make more money
they they want a guy that makes more
money than them and it's a smaller pool
some women but it depends because it
depends on what you're looking for in a
man
because i think there's so many more
important things in a man than money
what do you think is more important than
money oh my gosh where do i start a
decent man yeah
a decent man a family man a man who
respects women a man who is just
satisfied with just getting a good woman
so the money thing is secondary
why do you think women still pick the
guys that get multiple women though
because him historically 40 of men
reproduced where 80 of women reproduce
so there's two women for every one man
and even now it's an even smaller
percentage okay well i've got four sons
so i mean i i'm not helping the
situation it's all alone
i i i don't know it's just the way the
cookie crumbles i guess yeah
it's one of those do you think women are
attracted to men that other women want
or women are attracted to men that other
women want
to a certain degree i resent men like
that because
they demonstrate that they're not one
women
men yeah so you wouldn't if you've got
intelligence you wouldn't go for a man
like that you can't respect a man like
that what is the difference between a
woman playing hard to get and not being
interested
uh
to me to me uh i don't know
it's it's it's not that big of a
difference
so if it's she's playing hard to get
that that that that can also mean that
she's not entrusted so
do you do you think it's confusing for
men absolutely that's cc that's what i
was saying what it's like she's straight
interested not interested take a number
do you think women know what they want
ah absolutely 110
true
they do they do or they don't they do
they do they do know yes so do you think
when women say they want the nice guy
they actually want the nice guy no this
is a confusing situation this is the
confusing situation we have a nice guy
standing over there but the other night
the girl chose the bad guy not the nice
one
why do you think that is if women know
what they want but they say they want
the nice guy usually yeah they know they
they know what they want but they will
never tell the other person so okay so
it's like subconscious like they'll tell
you one thing but mean another and they
expect you to read their mind she said
that
what is the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested
[Music]
the difference between a woman housing
um
if she's not interested
she really cuts it off like there's
certain questions or certain things you
say and it's just like
there's no go but playing hard to get
she'll leave it a little bit flirty like
you'll be able to bite something but
with um just not interested it's cold do
you feel like women actually know what
they want
um
it's probably like the thing of age you
know like the older you get them you
kind of just learn like this is what i
like so i don't like okay last question
what is the worst date you've ever been
on
uh um
i haven't had a worse day sorry do you
think women actually like nice guys
a hundred percent really yeah
yeah
really from
from girls i talk to you
do you feel like those are the same guys
they sleep with
depending on the situation i mean okay
that is the first guy i've said say
yesterday what is the difference between
toxic masculinity and the masculinity
women are attracted to
i feel like toxic masculinity they do it
to get reactions out of women
and just the standard masculinity is the
man being the man so if you're using
your masculinity to get a reaction from
a woman that's toxic why is it when a
man makes money he wants more women but
when a woman makes money she said she
says she doesn't need a man
oh that's a tough question you know
i mean
if you think about it
i don't know it's like
it depends on like where you're from
like what what do you think what do you
think they want like because i think
guys think that with the money they can
attract more women but women since they
got all the like all the money they need
like somebody's going like i don't need
a man to take care of me yeah why don't
they do the same thing men do like if if
a guy gets a lot of money he's going to
sleep with a million women right
mostly in general yeah but if a girl
gets a lot of money she's like i don't i
don't need you like why doesn't she do
the same thing um
what
is the difference between toxic
masculinity and the masculinity women
are attracted to
toxic masculinity talk to masculinity is
like when you try to be
too like you try to be someone that
you're not like okay like when you're
trying to be too too manly instead of
being like the men you actually are
being being a man like
like it just comes natural you shouldn't
have to force yourself upon it like to
make it toxic like that's what makes it
toxic when you force it upon you
why is it when a man makes money he
wants more women but when a woman makes
money she feels like she doesn't need a
man i think it's because when a man
makes more money he feels like he's got
the power so it kind of feels like it
can buy anything you want just because
the fact that you have money but for the
woman it works differently it's because
of like cultural things like women
should only have one month but
men can have more than one it's more
like cultural thing to me i think do you
think it's more internal or external
like do you think it's because of the
culture or because of like how women are
i think it's more a cultural thing and
also how women feel like and the the the
women are meant just i think yeah it's
more cultural thing i think and how they
feel yeah okay it's more easy for a man
to have more than a woman but it's
really difficult for a woman to look
after more than one man really when you
think about it yeah yes
what is the worst date you've ever been
on
[Music]
i know i'm pretty good at dates i can
make the best out of any situation i
know one time i had one girl and it's
not her fault she just came
dressed like
frumpy it was just like she looked like
a mum
like and she
like it was just
it was just a bit like i don't i don't
care what she looks by just a bit she
didn't really try as well what is the
difference between
toxic masculinity and the masculinity
that women are actually attracted to
do you and do you think women know the
difference i don't know i was gonna just
say
that's like a borderline where i don't
know the difference but um toxic is like
i don't i don't even know how to explain
it because because you can't define it
yeah you kind of like to someone is like
yeah he's toxic but that's what i want
the other one's like he yeah he's so
toxic and then you see him with him next
week he's like
it's good toxic well i don't i don't
know that that one is weird to me what
is the worst date you've ever been on
worst day i've ever been on um i'm not
gonna lie i don't
i'm trying to think you're too charming
[Music]
so this his friend said he's charming no
when i say that i mean um the worst date
i've been on
i don't think i've had a bad day when i
when i say that
i'm kind of very
out front like because we're friends
we're
trying to not not trying to put
something on it where it's like you need
to meet this stand and if you don't meet
this standard i ain't seeing you it's
like at least just go over the floor and
hopefully you have a good time when i
have a good time yeah and that's it why
is it when a man makes money he wants
more women but when a woman makes money
she feels like she doesn't need a man
because when a man makes more money he
can
the man's role is to take care if he has
more money can take care of more women
when a woman
is self-sufficient and secure in herself
she won't need that from a man do you
feel like a girl making more money is
less attractive to a man or indifferent
uh depends on the man how secure he is
well i'm asking you oh no dan right yeah
i don't care if she's if she's made
money doing something she enjoys then
i always say it's kind of like a shoe
collection to a girl like we don't
really care if you have a shoe
collection do you feel like it's the
same thing with a girl's money like men
don't care about it
and i personally if she's making mad
money that's good on her okay
i don't make mad money but i make enough
money to be secure in what she makes
jenna why is it when a man makes money
he wants more women but when a woman
makes money she doesn't need a man
that's a good question um
i don't know i think that's that's just
uh
i don't even know
i don't even know
i don't know i can't relate it i can't
relate so i don't actually know the
answer to that question i'm assuming
that's more like um
something that's been kind of programmed
by like the movies like you see that a
lot of movies so maybe people just
assume that's the same in real life i
don't know do you think they mean it
when they say they don't need a man or
do you think they secretly want a man uh
depends on your preferences you know
like if you if you're not attracted to
men then or that's going to remain the
same isn't it yeah if like i think
i don't know i don't actually don't know
because i if you think about people that
do gain a lot of like finances
a lot of them are in relationships or
end up in relationships so i think their
standards of men changes because you go
up or down i think it goes up maybe you
want someone on your level your
financial level maybe yeah so it's like
a smaller pool yeah yes
do you think women actually like nice
guys
i think they like respect respectful
guys not nice guys not guys that get
pushed over but guys that would say you
know yeah we can do that for you baby no
i don't want to do that baby okay like a
guy that's not afraid to say no yeah
definitely not uh what is she just gonna
get whatever she wants
uh okay what is the difference between a
woman playing hard to get and not being
interested
a pl uh you can tell that a woman likes
you but she's trying to stay focused on
her thing and you respect that and
another woman that's just not interested
who
like she she'll let you know she's not
interested in
the way she talks the way she asks for
things what is the difference between a
woman playing hard to get and not being
interested
oh
and do you think women make it clear
not at all they don't make it clear at
all
uh
the difference
two minutes i don't know this one
i think they're both the same
they were playing hard to get or they
just don't care um
yeah i don't know do you think women
flirt for attention
sometimes
sometimes when you flirt because they're
bored i guess i can tell when people are
born and they're flirting
that's about it though do you think that
women go on dates for free food
hundred percent
ten percent
i would go on the date for free food
do you think women want to be equal to
man
sometimes yeah not all of them sometimes
they want to be equal and sometimes
they're like nah
i'd rather not like what
uh
equal in sense of getting paid okay but
then when it comes to stuff like
dates for example
yeah i don't want to pay you [ __ ] pay
for that so they only want it um they
only want it to be equal when it
benefits them yeah
pretty much
why don't we see protests for men not
getting let into bars for free
i don't think we care
to be honest i don't think we care that
much but if women want equality right
it's true
it's true
we should they should pay but we should
get you know
it's the life we live
do you think women flirt for attention
yeah definitely they get bored do you
think that makes it confusing for guys
yeah guys
um some guys especially guys who uh they
don't really understand women or maybe
they haven't grown around too many women
yeah they'll be like why did why does
she do that but people i know is like
cause she's a woman and that's that
that's the reason that's the reason
because you know that reason she gets a
bypass on everything
why is it when a man makes money he
wants more women but when a woman makes
money she doesn't need a man he said
that
what what if a woman wants more men
and a man wants one woman well that's
not typically what you see like um jeff
bezos why did he get divorced no he
cheated but some girl cheat on a guy oh
yeah for sure
but typically like the trend is if you
see if men make more money they cheat
more where women cheat less no i'm not
typical that's what i'm saying no the
stats like like they survey people and
ask them nah that's some people's
viewpoint if you look at it yeah no it's
not a viewpoint 50 50. okay if you do
that some girls eat some guys cheating
oh for sure for sure
more yeah
i think greed no it's um it's about 28
for men 25 for women so it's only three
percent but i'm saying when a man makes
over 250 thousand dollars he cheats 50
of the time where women they cheat like
a lower percentage of the time so
when they get the money they think
they've got it already yeah but why
don't women do the same thing
different mentality different mentality
yeah do you think women crave multiple
men or do you think they crave one
valuable guy
oh depends depends on the women
depending on the woman because saying
given the guy a guy might create
multiple women or god might create more
women
or one woman what is the difference
between a woman playing hard to get and
not being interested
um
i don't really know
i know only two with women
yeah you know you don't like girls no no
no i like girls but like i just i'm
always i'm always hooping i don't really
have time for
to be a part of women okay so so you've
never had a girlfriend never no
what why is it when a man makes more
money he wants more women but when a
woman makes more money she doesn't need
a man
um
i think the world is run by women so i
think they're the
stronger like
race if that makes sense like they're
stronger people so i feel like they
don't need to rely on anyone with
themselves men i feel like they need
women so
they feel like you have you have money
yes but like the thing that you actually
want and need is a woman so you want
more why do you feel like the world is
run by women when men hold most of the
power positions
and the infrastructure positions that's
that's the silly part of society i don't
believe it should just be run by men i
feel like women should definitely have a
big part as there's half and half people
in the world there's men and women so
yeah i think that's a city concept so
you think all jobs should be 50 50 100
yeah even the jobs that women don't want
to work like plumbing garbage electric
like some some women wouldn't mind you
know i'm saying like i'm not saying they
have to work the jobs that men work but
if they are willing and they want to
then i feel like they can put up just as
because of a job if women don't want to
then and it's like 99 what men do you
think that's a problem um not
necessarily no okay what is the
difference between a woman playing hard
to get and not being interested
playing hard to get and not be
interested
not interested is no replies at all not
even trying to talk to you
hard to get is
it's like a little game they're playing
with you you can tell already
do you think the games work
yeah of course yeah of course of course
it makes even more enjoyable
um do you think that women make it clear
the difference between the two or do you
think it's confusing for guys confusion
100 102 confusing do you think women
know what they want
oh no
no no wait no one knows what they want
like law firms can't keep women
over a certain age because they want to
go home and like be with their families
yeah they like have a hard time
retaining women no matter what they pay
them
because like over a certain age like
women just want to go home
have you know have you heard that or no
no but that's the first time you hear
that and even like certain jobs like
women don't want to work like garbage
electric plumbing
that's crazy yeah um
yeah that's one um okay what is the
worst first date you no you don't go on
dates you don't talk to girls do you
talk to girls
what's the worst first date i guess i've
been on a date yeah but like um
i would say
i don't know like just going to the
parks and something silly like not
really doing much just kind of chilling
i don't really like just just chilling
especially if you're not my girlfriend
if that makes sense so if you're not my
girlfriend i don't know just chill i
want to actually do something yeah like
learn something about you know what i'm
saying yeah what is the worst date you
have ever been on
so he said i'm gonna take you out i said
cool where are we going he goes
dress up
smart casual be ready at this time so he
came to pick me up everything was fine
went to the restaurant
went to pay got declined so i paid he
goes oh i'll give you cash just pay
the whole time the whole day i was
paying for everything and he was saying
he was going to give it to me in cash
and he never did did you go on another
date with no
you want to go home go to the edge where
did you meet him
dmgb oh he dm'd you on instagram
listening ladies don't also dms scary